e aí galera que assistiu ao canal tudo
vocês vai ter show em são luís em
construção em greve três jogos niterói
manaus belém fortaleza e mude lugar ver
que no site com seu ingresso e nós
estamos gravando os passos 26 matou
khamsa puto que eu dei meu dedo hoje
estará aí único na cabeça da gente se
preocupar em ter que preocupar com um
dedo que queimam que é cansativo para
gravar um filme no youtube daltiba cama
dormir acordei para gravar o seu
despertador para despertar do povo
também respeitado é chato eu me desperta
é tão chato acho que é por isso que a
gente acorda porque charneca do barulho
ao barulho em cacupé não fechar repete
que repetindo tem tem em tem e tudo se
repete é chato a gente acorda pudim
acorda feliz que o espectador
aquele dia mais o andershow mamãe
acho que vou procurar mary todos na área
mas doida shaq mais porque a gente
acorda concordando por despacho a
decisão correcta potente acorda
concordando com o espectador poderá
[Música]
planejar levantei a ó pronto cá e aí tô
aqui né então já que ele coloque gostei
concorda não gostei clica nele
faltava-me porque ele não tem amanhã ela
vai pegar é clicado ambos que tocava
nesse vídeo assim eu comecei a investir
na rica falei pra vocês tem 123 vídeo e
até escreveu falando sobre isso que eu
falei que eu fazer rádio colocar
dinheiro na poupança o dinheiro rende
mais e investir na regão então você tem
dinheiro você pode investir norte está
enganado um bom negócio 50 reais e já
consegue começar a investir inclusive o
pedido pelo rio para fazer um vídeo
especialmente pra você está assistindo
vídeos e aprender essa investidor hoje é
o primeiro link na descrição do vídeo
vai lá e se resume na coxa mas vamos
fazer na minha vida viajar conhecer o
mundo acho que esse mundo é muito grande
e eu só tenho uma vida para conhecer
tudo que tenha a conhecer esse mundo e
com esses meus peitos com um pouquinho
do viaja mais beleza comecei a viajar
mais só que nesses negócios viagem eu
não sei falar o negócio do inglês que
tem saber né
o inglês porque eu sei que disseram que
ele tem que aprender mas tem que saber
às vezes eu fico
indignado vou falar a verdade o pessoal
fala aprender inglês é muito importante
é de por que não que mais oportunidades
de trabalho porque você sabe inglês
e porque é que ninguém quer saber o
nosso que você já sabe o nosso aí fica
melhor e mais fácil vale inglês ainda
não se estudar e quando você vai para o
país e ainda sou melhor que você que
falou olimpíadas não pode porque aquilo
está preparado porque pessoas não sabe
falar inglês filho meu deus a desgraça
sai lá desgraças vem pra cá e eu tenho
que saber ler a desgraça porque ensinam
ou desgraça aí eu fico puto aí faz o que
eu faço humor né comédia eu escrevo
criou projetos o ator eu faço filme
então entregá fazer um negócio aqui e
claro só falei eu não sei porque você
não sabe inglês já entrei no meu país
fala botãozinho mas sem saber de suma
importância aí pra gente que fica
difícil da ses o pinheiro é você tudo
bom faz alguma coisa não nada ao inglês
fluente em praga está pesando 200
garotos
eu fico sem entender o negócio inglês lá
eu vou na índia é só para inglês não
tocará e fui lá em falar em inglês
porque que tem que saber falar claro lei
porque todo mundo tem que aprender a
língua de vocês você tem que aprender a
língua de ninguém porque a gente tem um
mickey itabom tem que aprender inglês
que é importante quem sabe é importante
um mendigo dos estados unidos é melhor
que você é fã de lady gaga falou a bola
branca e vão aprender pronto é pra falar
inglês
vou falar então tá bom o que é difícil
para muitas pessoas é fácil muita gente
era muito fã não se só pegar o jeito ou
dois é fácil pegou o jeito a cpi começou
a ter 12 baixaria no bairro que diz que
não tem jeito [ __ ] que o senhor mim o
mais difícil nós em inglês árabe por
exemplo secular do ensino foi meu
dentista lá com a boca aberta e aí ficou
metal show eu ah ah ah ah aí falando é
capa da playboy na irlanda meu deus do
céu só falam é só ter paciência é bem
fácil é bem fácil porque eu não sei esta
merda aí meu carro apreendido com que dá
né eu aprendi muito com forno por onde
agora tudo primeira vez que os estados
unidos a maior turnê mendes foto conhece
conhece ou não xingue
eu tô pará deixou o cara chega àquele o
maboque obeidi o prefeito ballin dela
só que é muito depois que cheguei muito
tempo aqui a gente resolve um segundo
aponta que parei o carro tem de aprender
nesta cárter michael agora porque é que
é tão complicada não consigo entender o
egípcio é mais fácil eo inglês não é o
egipto egípica fala eu quero um gato que
ele faz e desenha [ __ ] do gado é isso
aqui é um garoto passei me odiando gente
acha o da pedra que está escrito está
dizendo que ele viu na agência que sei
que o sol mas ele faz ele vai lá na pele
de reserva do sol baixa 3 milhões de
anos que se que um sol tá vendo que o
mar o sol o egípcio quer dizer ah eu
quero falar a língua que é complicado e
devem à porta do mickey pessoa acha
catatumbo william depois que está
escrita que ele escreveu sistêmica a
dizendo à rede abevê em inglês que é
muito importante é o farol saber pois a
primeira aula me fiquei agoniada tudo da
mesma idade da equipe ney diz né faça
isso impede nem faça aquilo pensei que
toda hora make you make you make me
aquele jogador ou metais ela descobre
que jacques abandonar a meio de junho da
jet2 dânao cheguei em casa agora vou
sair para espairecer para ele só fazer o
meia allan e ramon meia bomba pronta a
make abordar o galego perigosa perigosa
ela bota mesmo não se nunca quando se
rouba mesmo perante a pessoa que por si
inglês é bom se agora passe epic também
por si bolsa possui que quer dizer na
pronúncia card um rc pode estar pedindo
o bolso um pequeno tem como aprendeu a
língua que bota na sinuca de bico 10 o
cara pensava comprar bolsa e você tem
que analisar muito bem as situações
porque veja bem o cenário porque se está
num cabaré e pedir um brinquedo e
acidentalmente a pronúncia e pede roubou
só que agora se tu tá na loja de bolsas
será pedir pro mulher e acidentalmente o
pega um preto com migas em conservatória
de repente eu sou até preso perigoso num
dia de citar nos estádios
mãe ligou pra mim não estava boa para
mim e eu levo na roma impeça qualquer
coisa uma mesa table bem fácil de falar
table já viajei muito pelo mundo é 30
países já não às vezes não é só conhecer
a língua da pessoa que conheceu os
gestos e tem conhecer as pessoas
entenderam para poder entender eu
gravando os passos 2 agora então chinês
que trabalha com a gente vai servir
chinesa muito com a cabeça machucada
ontem já não tinha um chinês também era
a mesma coisa lá a tim burton huawei não
eu fui na itália eu percebi italiana
fala muito com a mão sempre assim na não
sei falar italiano não te falar nem
português direito é guy é sempre cheio
pelas mãos e quando eu fui na índia eu
percebi que as pessoas falam muito com a
cabeça e com as mãos de renato toque
eu acho que é o que eu falo muito com a
cabeça com a mãe com o novo mapa ver é
este livro é dona chama banda gostou do
vídeo clipe nosso tempo amanhã a liga
gay pela angelus comentário foi ali que
você acha mais difícil outra coisa pode
investir seu dinheiro meu amigo pense
que precisa ser milionário que
investiram 50 coxim 50 reais 770 sendo
dá para investir e uribe fez um vídeo
especial para você está assistindo que
você aprender a investir primeiro na
descrição do vídeo corre lá se cadastrar
rico faz só com o dia ea hora todo mundo
se dando bem viajando o mundo e aprender
inglês é importante né eu tenho um nome
que eu provei jam
valeu